what is happening there reject nation tara
erickson is back with me today after i covered
in kanto so many people were like you gotta do
turning red next and i was like okay it's a movie
about like a 13 year old girl that's all i pretty
much know something to do with a panda i need
someone who's really in touch with their youth so
i brought my 55 year old friend tara erickson by
to watch us you excited tara yeah i am excited
you can see how young i am by these overalls
yeah it really captures the 1950s you grew
up in guys leave a like if you can that'd
be very much appreciated also full length
watch along as we sync up with the time code
for turning around will be at our patreon
page thank you to all who have joined us
over there so far your support means a
lot follow tara erickson on all the crap
that i've linked in the description box and pin
comment she's only here for attention let's do
it and the prepper boys thanks for helping
us edit this down now let's really do it
the number one rule in my family honor
your parents the least you can do in return
is every single thing they ask be careful
honoring your parents sounds great but if
you take it too far well you might forget to honor
yourself very true true i don't have that problem
euphoria
it's heaven
my mom cuts his hair at the salon
and i felt it it's very soft
he looks like a hobo a hot hobo
and aaron t and aaron z are like really
talented too we are four townies remember
oh my god i miss boy bands
and here is your reward 99 australian tour
o m g mirror i'll guard it with my life
did they say omg in 1994 i don't think yes
clueless was like in the 90s oh yeah okay
never mind of course they said omg what is
wrong with me that's such a common thing
responsibilities man i have
responsibility yeah check it out oh
that's my little scholar the
ancestors would be so proud
our most revered ancestor was a scholar poet
and defender of animals ever since the red
panda has blessed our family good fortune
and prosperity and can bless yours too
i'm sorry you grew up white
can't relate to any of this
come on dad's making dinner
disney knows how to make food look so
good every freaking time i'm like are
we in ratatouille again yeah look how delicious
that looks oh why are we not eating right now
fourth down we'll be kicking
off near north american poor
oh my gosh who are these hip hoppers and why are
they called four town if there are five of them
wow she erases into the trash wow she
really is an a-type personnel i don't
get what mir sees in him he's not that cute okay
his shoulders are kind of nice his eyes are oh no
it's just an infatuation man it's not
gonna last you're not even an adult
oh my god she's glad clothes from fatal attraction
do you want a snack cool great
thanks don't look at the notebook
who is he did he do these things know
that hat is that the sketchy clerk from
the daisy mask oh my god what tight
oh my god it's gonna get violent he's a
sweet innocent child how dare you take
advantage of her mom no what are
you thinking mom god mom oh my god
why is he a mermaid
this will never happen again no girl but it will
toronto man some repressed [ __ ] up in there
oh my god what what is this love
crafty and crap what is going on here
oh my god it's begun
are you sick is it a fever a stomachache chills
constipation did the red peony bloom no huh
what maybe but it's too soon don't worry meimei
i'll get everything you need oh oh i just got it
a hot water bottle and pants oh cool i love
that pixar's dude i did not expect this
something to be embarrassed about mom
you are now a beautiful strong flower
i never thought i'd see a pixar movie
where they have that conversation
that's just crazy man blows my mind woke woke
hollywood talking about things every woman goes
yes so the pandas are just a big
metaphor for female puberty right
i don't know extra snacks and herbal tea for
cramps it helps relax you i got it thank you bye
there's so much i could learn as a man from this
movie maybe the red panda is who she actually is
this is just a front for her mother god
tyler is an insecure jerkwad end of stone
oh there you go huh uh may why are you
staring at carter murphy mayhew i wasn't
no tyler is putting these
up what they're everywhere
alone it's like the movie black swan
oh god
oh my god
tell him
oh red panda
be careful
what's happening to me what is it what's
happened already already what did you say
you know a little warnings would have been very
beneficial our ancestor son ye had a mystical
connection with red pandas she loved them so
much that she asked the gods to turn her into one
the gods granted her wish they gave
her the ability to harness her emotions
to transform into a powerful mystical beast
protect her village and save her family from ruin
cool sunny passed this gift to her daughters
and they passed it to theirs but over time
our family chose to come to a new
world and what was a blessing became
an inconvenience yeah a little
has that would have been nice yeah
it happened to me you'll undergo a ritual
that will seal your red panda spirit
into one of these you only have one chance
to banish it and you cannot fail otherwise
you'll never be free hmm be the 25th that's a
whole month away we'll wait it out together and
i will be with you every step of the
way you have to accept your emotions
guys what are you doing go away are you
okay tap if you can hear us two for now
four times coming to toronto
all right i'm gonna let go
and you're gonna be chill
chill hey i'm sloppy i'm smelly
my mom won't even look at me and
no four towns go go become women without
me oh that's sad i'm never not by
all right we love you mae you're our girl
yeah no matter what panda or no panda
they adjusted her being a
panda remark really quick
and you look amazing red looks so
good is it gone for now but if i get
too excited it'll come right back out
something feels different abby hit me
you can come with us to four towers yeah i
can't ask my mom i'm a furry digging time bomb
crap you guys better go but no butt smear my
mom already doesn't like you she doesn't oh
ready said orangutan your second place spelling
bee trophy the important thing is you tried you
spelled your little butter first place
in our hearts oh she needs nurturing
just go to the concert as a panda
when i start to get emotional
all i do is imagine the people
i love most in the whole world
which is you guys oh oh i just have one
teeny tiny favor to ask no absolutely not
oh man i just want to broaden my musical horizons
and it's not worth jeopardizing your life over
right jin see your father agrees no concert
god damn it dad there's no way she could
keep her panda in and 200 unbelievable i
saw that look where did she get that from
treating her own mother like that
me it's your mother i'm not here
oh it's generational i know about maymay i was
just about to call you no one knows anything
they barely saw her i'm on my way with
reinforcements no i can handle it i can
you guys need to stand up to your
mom's man sometimes she's just so
no wonder mae is such a loser
eat him come on eat her panda yeah
they don't trust us anyway
then what's the point wow this
is our first step into womanhood
we'll say it's a sleepover at my house
my mom will never know now we just
got to raise the money for tickets
come on girls think karaoke use the panda a little
panda abby come on mate it'll clear my mind ha
mermaid
get it right i'll give you anything
money my kidney my soul yeah
cool monetize the payout
oh my god i want those sticky earrings
those are 90s greg i know right
it felt like a real song from the 90s mom is
gonna look under the bed and it's all gonna go to
[ __ ] when she's just learning to embrace herself
i mean i love it but find a
better spot than under the bed
nice cat are you a triangle cause you were cute
i want to throw a sick birthday party an epic
one if you're there everyone will come simple
as that i've done you a favor keeping my mouth
shut all i'm asking for is one bet you're a
manipulative little dick you know that man oh
do it tylers are always jerks guys 200 bucks
will put us over the top hey dork bag we're in
okay i'm heading off to mathletes wouldn't you
rather hang with dad oh let's get my flash
cards oh crap but i don't want you to find ellie
oh [ __ ]
oh they want to see the oh no it's scrap oh god
you better guess that party man oh god run each
time you do the stronger it gets and then you'll
be bound to it your mother and i were close once i
couldn't bear to see that happen to you so no more
panda it wasn't the panda you were your mother's
whole world mimi i know you do what's right oh
jeez constantly guilted man hey tyler you want
the panda you're getting the panda let's hear it
oh god
no bueno man mimi needs a strong hand
now more than ever don't let her
out of your sight i won't mother
it's not the panda girls it's your possessive
nature right yeah that's what i was trying to
say okay good picking up on things i'm a man so
i don't understand things you're getting closer
uh see under the bed like
i said it's not a good spot
oh her grades are failing
mimi what is
we are walking into that concert girls and coming
out women guys i can't be like this forever my
whole family would freak especially my mom all her
hopes and dreams are pinned on me no four towns
the same night is the ritual no the same night the
same night you want your money then get your butt
down here now go back to your psycho mom and and
your creepy temple you freak oh you little racists
what is going on here i am so sorry
we haven't caught you never to have
good thoughts before i don't know what
came up i don't want to hear your apology
no one mentioned this is a horror movie
man we just wanted to see four town
four town you manipulated her for a bunch of
tacky delinquents no she wanted to don't you
blame her she is a good girl and you've taken
advantage of her mate tell her oh may speak up
leaving her friends in the dust
you gotta kill your mom how
many tickets three please
what is that um i think it's coming from
the skydome mother four is the worst number
hurry up everyone it's almost time to stop
the ritual the red moon is about to begin
oh dad buy her the tickets people have all
kinds of sides to them the point isn't to
push the bad stuff away it's to make room
for it this side of you made me laugh
it's kind of horrifying
and return the red panda
spirit from where it gains
oh
now destroy toronto
oh my god i'm going to the concert uh-oh
is mommy's red panda gonna come out now
this is a disaster uh-oh
she's out of control oh yeah
oh snap panda wars
pretty cool that's dope
ah you never needed to buy a ticket losing
you guys feels even worse well too bad or
down forever for town forever forever tyler no
tyler i don't know what time are a four tony yeah
who cares what's she gonna do ground me
oh my god oh my god what is happening
they are gonna destroy tyrande
oh my god it's not gonna be them it's
gonna be our mom this is so unexpected
what is going on right now
oh
i told you she was big oh my
god i'm shutting this down
everyone go home where are your
parents put some clothes on
this finale is so much bigger than i thought
wow mom you have to get in the
circle sunny give me strength
oh my gosh poor mimi grandma i am not
losing my daughter don't just stand there
oh
this is
sky baby
i hurt her who my mom i got so angry and i and
i lost control oh that's where her scar's from
guide you and keep you safe maymay's
keeping the panda it's her life
you guys did so much property damage um
the farther you go the prouder i'll be
people still talk about panda apocalypse
2002 you ready let's do this hello
welcome to our temple and the only one that's
home to the great red panda monetize your daughter
i'll be back before dinner okay fine oh
um you're welcome to join us for mr lee's
cooking uh yeah don't load up on jump thanks
for covering for me you've all got a messy loud
weird part of ourselves hidden away and a lot
of us never let it out but i did how about you
i'm batman
i got real snotty there uh there's a
point where i was real really crying there
i'll get you uh some toilet paper i think
my fingers will do and these overalls every
movie i watched lately i ended up crying
everything every movie huh why chicks
why do they feel the need to disguise themselves
did you like it i did it wasn't a typical like
star movie it took a second it was a little slow
but i liked it i liked the message at
the end that little repressed bully
like in the beginning you know in pixar movies it
literally takes them two minutes for you to super
care about the the lead character basically
something's really traumatic to me yeah yeah
it's just like the a type of like disney thing
we get it this just took a different path but i
enjoyed it i think that's why i called it
slow in the beginning because i was like
well where is this going i think there was more
opportunities for jokes in the beginning but
i liked it it's a different kind of pixar movie
and i enjoyed it it's weird they do things that
maybe aren't as like traumatically heft i would
say yet there is a certain type of more i think
relatable type of trauma that a lot of us go
through as adults that we don't realize it's funny
because i was i was just speaking with a friend of
mine uh yesterday at the the moon night premiere
marvel cool just saying i gotta i attended that
vlog with the kazoo i'm like where is going with
this very long punch nobody had any idea it's the
i went to the thing and um what's up with my
friend wendy pointedly from the movie couple
channel i'm half asian and i grew up with my asian
family and then wendy's foolish one thing i was
we were talking about was like i've never seen
such a different type of generational gap like
a specific type than with a lot of and maybe just
because i grew up asian uh but with like asians
from asia and then like asian americans or toronto
right because the culture is so different of like
it's so disciplinary and hardcore and i think
that it goes further beyond than just like
asian culture in this like this is something
that i think a lot of people struggle with
but that whole conundrum of of uh you know like a
lot of times you know if you're not from you know
imagine still happens in asia too but everyone
out here that i would always meet has that same
thing of like my parents are like this and i feel
the need to like be more expressive and be myself
and get in touch with my emotions and not just
go down the path my parents want me to go down
and that's a common type of argument i see happen
or it's the other side where they do feel like
they go down that path but they don't really want
to yeah all asian parents are bad or something
so this is something i i notice around here in
california and so seeing it represented here was
uh interesting but i think they still managed to
make it universal because i think we all know what
it's like yeah we have to just be obedient to our
parents i mean it was pretty obvious with like the
even though tyler wasn't in it a lot but he is
the bully that was like a suppressed like with
all this repressed anger a bully and then he turns
into one of their like one of the girls and he
likes uh oh town i keep i want to say oh town it's
four town but it's modeled after ohtown from 2001.
yeah you guys remember ohtown and i'm like oh
that's the perfect example of like tyler was like
you know he's a bully because he had all
this like repressed stuff i think disney
pixar especially has been dealing a lot with re
generational repression mm-hmm that's why i just
would just watch the encounter you've seen a kanto
right yeah and like that had the same thing but
like yeah that was this one grandma lineage and
like oh it stems from there of trying to satisfy
and please or go down a certain path but a lot
of it is leads to unintentionally forcing your
children to repress the way they feel it's like
this yeah lately it's like this message of like
psychological embrace and accept yourself
it's been like a lot of the message i think
i've seen people sometimes say with this movie
i've only i didn't know what it was actually
about me neither but i've heard some of the things
of like that's not as universally accessible
usually hearing this from men and i thought that
like okay so what is it no it is not experience
emotions like a teenager i'm like i still think
this is pretty relatable even for me i'm like
no there's a lot i can relate to in this and
like wanting to please your parents when you're
young and wanting to and like sexual hormones
and you like boys and you don't want to like
express it because everyone's like try to tap that
down it's awkward yeah yeah this is very real it
just is not as like i guess uh what what does it
need to be like spelled out so that it looks like
how you need it to look how you look it's called
metaphors yeah i think there's like i was more
interested in in those correlations than i was the
you know anything with like the actual ritual of
the panda and stuff i like i like everything it
represented i liked everything and metaphorically
talked about it was like amusing but i wasn't that
into that whole goal of like we got to go to four
town like that right wasn't that engaging to me
right but i was going it probably means something
deeper than just going to see the ban right i
think some people might check it because i had
to remind myself that like there's probably a much
deeper meaning to this whole action of making sure
she's going to go to this concert you know right
like how she's going about it too the journey of
you know embracing herself and accepting herself
doing what she wants to do is really what it's
about but yeah that whole ending scene
with the panda and the mirror dimension
was really it was really beautiful it was really
making me a really misty and i was really crying
a lot there yeah that's a good message i mean
it's like all of the generations up to our mom
like you can see that they're all pretty much
kind of the same person followed a path yeah
didn't find themselves and then she did and then
she meets with her ancient ancient grandma who's
like i didn't follow that path either well i think
it worked best as like this like slice of life
thing that had this larger than life fantasy
quality with the panda i like the simplicity
of that yeah so when it got like really big in the
end i felt like the message started getting a bit
muddled a little bit tiny bit except for they
all went back to being without the panda except
for her yeah yeah so they let her have her
own choice so yeah like it made sense to me
it just when it got so big of like like a kaiju
battle you know i agree it was sort of like where
where this is uh a little out of tone i guess
tonally like yeah a little like i i don't know
if it was needed to be that large i don't think it
needed to go that big i was i didn't i felt like
they needed it like adventure and we needed
to be big and then she needs to like almost
die and then we have to like pull her back and ho
town comes back and apparently there's still kids
behind the rubble like that we're like we saw all
these like big pandas and one the one almost died
and they were like we knew oh town would come
back they're like peeking out i was like all right
that's a little that's a little weird it was still
very entertaining though it was entertaining like
it was amusing it was cool to look at but i
did start getting like yeah i feel like it's
kind of losing some of the the part the heart
of it that i really love with the magic was the
the simplicity of it while i agree like yeah it's
a really like pretty simple story and it's not
something that because they usually like pixar
when they want to go weighty are going live
really existential like wall-e or some [ __
] yeah before they go like really just like
traumatic opening like up yeah like really
get you hard there is a post-credit scene
dad's like tyler he's he's still a
little repressed but yeah he was a bully
all right we'll finish reviewing it in three two
one so dad likes four town too who wouldn't like
four town i know everybody i thought it was gonna
be more 90s leaning because like they said in 94
and i thought it would be like oh it is yeah at
the beginning it's in 94 and that's why there
was the best oh okay tara is so old she thinks
nsync came out like five years ago she's like
backstreet boys is still around right genie in
a bottle from christina it just came out maybe
those are good songs those are great songs they're
great bands man great bands okay now it's all
about k-pop which is great which is great actually
it's a lot much more impressive but yeah um
yeah i i mean i it's weird like this guy's a
good critic scoring and i saw the audience had
like a pretty big divide with it and i'm like i
guess it's just not like i wouldn't say it's like
bottom t i mean it's not top tier pixar for me
but it's not i wouldn't be like it's bottom tier
no it's pretty good i feel like people just don't
get metaphors or they don't like understand the
message there like maybe mom didn't need to change
into a panda like maybe it needed to be like the
kid stays but her and mom come together i mean we
all knew that her and mom would come together in
the end yeah and i feel like uh i don't know i
i don't know why people wouldn't i feel like if
you make it through to the end of the movie you
you have to be like yeah there's a good message
there yeah maybe they just didn't they didn't want
mom to like go go back to who she was even though
she didn't fully but she did make the choice to
be without her pen and keep it in like all the
rest of them did yeah they kept it in a gray area
yeah which i appreciate the gray area because um
like if mom was like no i'm not i'm not going i'm
going to stick by my daughter and also keep the
panda i'm like no that would be out of character
not saying that that's what people wanted why they
didn't like the movie they probably just didn't
like it for other reasons but well i could see why
people wouldn't like i mean because of the fact
i think there's the the the thing of its pixar so
you kind of add a little bit more critical eye on
what you expect what you expect yeah yeah because
it does follow it this does not follow the tropes
of pixar no and it doesn't have quite the the well
this is more like the onward category like you've
seen onward yeah like yeah or something yeah um
but not something like soul yeah which like those
are like it's like elevated pixar yeah and while
i think this it go it still has the impressive
animation and really great voice work and stuff
um yeah for the most part it felt like i don't i
really think it's beautiful to look at at the same
time i'm not like i needed to have seen this in
the theaters no no no no no no good i still would
recommend it like i recommend it i think there's
so much great things in it it's also funny a lot
of the time too oh yeah yeah i mean what's that
movie about where they're angry and they're the
marbles that represent anger inside out thank you
so much that movie i was like oh i wish i would
have seen this in theaters because i don't think
yeah i watch it on my tv that i feel very strongly
like that movies i feel more strongly connected
to like maybe those classic like pixars i mean
obviously all the other ones like up i can't
even i can't watch that movie more than
more than twice i will never watch it again it's
one of my most favorite movies but i'm like it's
too emotional for me but um this i don't think
i'd be like click on it and be like i'm gonna
watch it again but i think i would tell people
to be like oh you should definitely watch it
to be like to get the message yeah see a different
thing from pixar and what they can do because the
message is still there and pixar is very good
at giving lessons i think and you know it's
it is interesting i i don't know like to me
it just threw me like for a loop when they
are talking about like reproductive qualities
right i'm like oh i'm so used to seeing i guess
now right in in typical movies with real like a
kids movie you're not gonna be yeah and like a
kid's animated movie i'm like it's pg and i'm like
okay that makes more sense right because when you
weren't talking about like going like going like
because it's also like a big puberty metaphor this
whole film yeah like this is yeah it's not even
just a metaphor it's just that's what's happening
she's going through puberty right and so when they
are talking about that it's you know i could see
how the context of the whole panda thing is all
representative of that one especially when they
make the scene the introduction scene of
that about her having a period like right
the mom's registering what's happening right
and to me to just the fact that they're even
having that discussion in an animated kids movie
was like oh i did not expect this movie to even
bring up such subjects yeah like it was surprising
yeah um but i don't know if that like upsets
so groups of the i don't want to spend forever
trying to die like what do people like but i
was i was actually i give it credit for um i'm
being willing to do that yeah yeah i feel like
i'm desensitized as i watch so many things and
there's so many films out there that i guess
like 13 year olds aren't watching but maybe like
teenagers could watch where they do deal with like
oh someone helping the girl with their period it's
awkward for mom or dad they don't have to deal
with it but um i guess in an animated it's like
everyone goes to see pixar or pixar is regarded as
safe and they don't do too many topics at least
not as of like and maybe until now that are like
reaching that like puberty and stuff like that
where she's like all the details of it all the
details of it and her drawing like him and getting
like heated and yeah and then talking boys and
yada yada uh yeah i guess you're right i'm like oh
that's weird that they haven't done that until now
where it's more in your face which this one was
yeah obvious so i'm thinking about it in terms
of like if i saw it on like anything else i would
be like okay yeah but for this for like a disney
pixar like oh wow they're doing it yeah she did
it yeah that's what i said in the 90s because
she could just access the internet and for
all her freakish oh right furry desires right
mermaids yeah i wanted to go on my phone and
look online some some max free websites here
they had to limit themselves ah i did think the
the friends i love what the friends represented
as a support group and what it feels like
to have your friends as family but not
feel like the ones you could really love
and feel the love and trust from is your
your actual family i think that's a really
relatable thing yeah like while i watch this
i i can definitely be like yeah it's nothing
more targeted towards a female audience than
someone like me at the same time i'm like all the
emotional things the context of all the emotional
surroundings i think are very relatable for for
men yeah who don't just go anger don't push it
down you know feel the need to cry once in a
while like a real man yeah oh god k-pop yeah
so you get ladies is it just that
that's move that and say you cry i cry
i cry i think it worked everybody's wet out
there yeah with emotions in their eyes yes sure
that's what she meant yeah no no it's not
we're not gonna get demonetized no no no no
no no no one stupid joke but from the eyes duh
no when you cry a lot it was wet on your face
what all in your face everywhere is what
i meant that doesn't sound good either so
we'll just stop we'll just try to stop oh stop
staying wet stop saying what and we'll be fine
okay i'm gonna change subjects you can
make a panda cinematic universe like this
ah first in kung fu panda oh yeah yeah
yeah what you like meeting they get no
that's they cross over two different they did it
with the spiderman they can do it with the pandas
one is universal and one is disney they'll never
come together it's kung fu panda universal yeah
all right well there's your lesson for today
universal versus disney i give it like a
seven point eight out of ten hey that's pretty
good yeah yeah i'll give it a seven out of ten
even though you didn't ask i think he wanted me
to give probably a rating or he was like forget it
you know i felt that once the man has stated that
yeah the ratings you don't
need a woman do we really need
sure i get it no big deal seven out of ten okay
whatever makes you feel better that peaked in
there yeah okay right so they'll yeah listen
guys uh follow tara on her social media yeah
she has to drive home now oh my god oh wait
you gotta wait an hour it's gonna be like a
long drive la traffic baby here for it
um hey but tara can you help me do it
tara can you shout out our friend deonte
aka tongue punch fartbox deonte tongue punch
think is that good i think adam all the
times we have tried to finding inventive
ways to shout out tongue punch park
pucks not once did we actually try to do
wow they didn't actually try to do it i'm telling
fart bucks with my mouth all right deontay you
need to come over to my patreon baby now leave
them just for a week give me the one monthly
payment you can come right back just you know
because i understand you and maybe they don't
do i apparently not they don't i thought we
had something but clearly we have grown apart
and now you i'm locking it down you guys gotta
share your punch fart boxes thank you deontay